there's a thing in the book i forget
what drug you were on
but you spend the night in mexico in a
cage with a lion
a mountain lion it described to me
you were on peyote so at sunrise that
morning i went with the shaman on a solo
triple walk up this
this mountain about a six mile hike and
as a good shaman will do disseminate the
peyote in small
small doses along the way and and to go
do something physically active is a very
smart thing out there if you're ever
gonna do
uh peyote don't just lock yourself in
your room you might implode
we returned to the shaman's house
and had this cage with this full-grown
mountain lion in it
i went up to the edge of the cage and
started to get the idea that i'm going
to get on the same frequency as this
mountain lion
and so i start probably listening to the
mountain lion it's burning around i'm
getting down there i get my base tone on
the histogram
about a 30 minutes go by finally outline
comes over to the cage and comes through
and kind of
i'm sitting there scratching under his
chin
and he's starting to like this well now
i get the bright idea that i'm going to
slowly move
into the gate and slowly walk into the
cage
and i'm moving extremely slowly while
this mountain lion's pacing on the other
side of the cage now i'm in
and i'm like keep your cool stay on the
frequency here
cut to two hours later that sunbitch was
laying in my lap purring
what yeah
looking at my lap purring and
i hung out there and i was in that cage
for just about over three hours and then
when it was time to get up i slowly got
up and walked out
and then yeah later that night i had
that moment of what you just said
what the [ __ ] but it made complete sense
at the time and it worked
there was no fear on your part that this
predator was going to eat you
yeah there's a little bit of fear i knew
that that cat and i that mountain lion
were communicating at the time i was
smart enough to know that that cat was
not that mountain lion was not starving
all right it had been it had been fed
okay so i felt pretty confident that if
i went in and approached it the right
way
that i would not be on the menu
you